uh
right good afternoon and welcome to our
midday briefing sorry let me get rid of
this
today is wednesday the 9th of march
so the war in ukraine as you know has
already forced over 2 million people
to flee their homes
seeking safety protection
and assistance
many more displaced people are on the
move both inside
and outside
ukraine
their need of shelter and basic
information about how to prepare
to leave their rights in the eu and
information about onward travel
you know that we had a press conference
yesterday in strasbourg on the support
which the european union is providing
and
today
to make sure that
the information that is most valuable
for
these
people who are on the move reaches them
the commission has launched a web page
with information to assist them
throughout their journey to the eu and
within
the eu you can see here
behind me
a couple of
points of what is described on this
webpage
it is currently available in english but
we are working flat out to make it
available as well
in ukrainian and it should be available
by tomorrow in
ukrainian you will find more information
of course on this in our daily news we
will try to make sure that there is a
short
name
that it's easy to find on the
on web browsers so that people can
easily get to this
to this webpage it has been built
extremely quickly and therefore we're
still working on it but we thought it
was important to publish it as quickly
as possible and then improve it
as
as we go
this web page is part of a broader
website which
we have put online which also describes
on the one hand all of the actions which
the european union has taken in the
context of inva of the invasion of
ukraine and secondly also provides many
examples of the absolutely fantastic
initiatives that are taking place on the
ground in the member states and in other
neighboring countries in order to help
to help the people affected by this
invasion
foreign
catherine
you have the floor
hello can you hear me yes go ahead
hi my question is on energy
um
the greek prime minister has asked the
eu to intervene temporarily in energy
market regulation and bruno le mayor
said this morning he's convinced that
the commission will put forward some
kind of intervention soon even if it's
just temporary so my question is
uh is intervention on the table in the
market and if so what could that look
like thank you
thank you very much
question for tim
yeah thanks catherine um well the
commission proposed yesterday the
outlines of a plan as i as i'm sure you
saw called repower eu
which is about making uh europe
independent from russian
russian fossil fuels starting with gas
well before the end of the decade
um the plan also contains measures to
respond to high energy prices
these include guidance for member states
on regulating prices in exceptional
circumstances
redistributing revenues from high energy
sector profits and from emissions
trading to consumers and it also refers
to the measures under eu state aid rules
and which are available to
to support businesses um
i mean our goal is to keep electricity
affordable without disrupting supply and
further investment in the green
transition and i think i mean what i
will say now is what you've surely read
in the communication yesterday
to address the current extraordinary
circumstances we will look into all
possible options for emergency measures
to limit the contagion effect of gas
prices on electricity prices such as
temporary price limits
we will consult as a matter of urgency
or concerned actors and propose options
in the coming weeks
we will also assess options to optimize
the electricity market design to reap
the benefits from low-cost energy
so the communication as i said confirms
the measures um which are already in
place and it gives them very detailed
guidance on how those can be used by
member states in the annexes to the
communication
and that's i think as far as i can go
for now we'll see um how the
conversation continues in the coming
days when the leaders meet in versailles
thank you tim uh are there other
questions on energy
for
tim
please only keep your hand uh raised in
the uh platform if it's on energy i see
one hand raised
marina
yes i i have a question regarding the
energy so we saw the the the um decision
of united states yesterday to ban the
oil and gas from from russia is is there
a possibility for european union to do
something like this is there on the
table at all that is there something to
to to say about this and is it possible
to do this uh regarding the dependency
of eu and the the thing that you just
mentioned during uh
the the the plan for eu to to reduce
slowly the the dependency of the guests
thank you
tim
yeah thanks marina so our partners in
washington and also in london uh with
whom we continue to coordinate very
every step very closely have decided to
to ban oil imports from russia as you
say
um europe uh the united states also the
european uh sorry the united kingdom um
agree that we need to wean ourselves off
russian energy as soon as possible i
referred to the plan presented yesterday
repower eu
how we can do that how we can reduce our
demand our dependence on russian gas
already by two-thirds this year
uh i think this issue will certainly be
discussed among leaders at the summit in
versailles in the second half of this
week
what's crucial
is that russia immediately ceases its
attacks on ukraine and seriously seeks a
solution at the negotiating table
the eu has launched three packages of
very tough sanctions against russia and
belarus and is prepared to present
further sanction packages if that
becomes necessary
thank you
we continue with the energy topic
ekrem you have a question on energy
yes
i was reading carefully yesterday the
the
the proposals for the commission
but
in terms of short-term uh uh
period reaching uh the the goal of
reducing
30
this year
if you can eventually uh give us more
details how far can i have gone the
discussion with azerbaijan of redoubling
the 10 uh bcm
uh
uh
this year or next year because initially
the plans for with azerbaijan were was
were
like 25-26
and now you have some talks with
azerbaijan so where are we now exactly
now
uh with these talks uh uh currently
and then in terms of um
the american lng
element moved quite a lot since uh the
junker trump agreement in july 2018
and then now the uh the lng represents
uh american lng represents like six
point eight percent in the first six
months last year
so
how much the the american uh lng can fit
in
and and and uh
come to the rescue
together with with azerbaijan in short
term like by the end of the year or
having those 90 capacities or 80
capacities of storage
for the the next winter
tim
yeah so ekrem um if you've been reading
the communication you will see that we
have a table in there i think it's page
five or six of the communication which
sets out the numbers in terms of where
we think the different measures can
reduce
reduce demand or replace
demand
in
in the next year and also going forward
to the 2030 horizon so just to give you
the headline figures we think that
through lng
diversification finding alternative lng
sources
we can find
50 billion cubic meters
by the end of 2022
and pipeline gases we think we can find
an extra 10 uh 10 billion cubic meters
by the end of this year so that's the
the headline figures uh in terms of
where that comes from specifically it's
it's a range of uh sources and we've
talked about that um repeatedly the us
is one of those and we've seen
a significant increase in u.s lng
arrivals in january and february of this
year i don't have the percentage off the
top of my head but it's i mean it's it's
uh an increase quite a market increase
on the number that you mentioned there
which i think you said was the the first
half
of last year
as regards azerbaijan
as you say the the pipeline they're
increasing and the flows does require
some investments and we've we've had
conversations with our with our partners
there about that and we also need to
discuss um with other countries um where
where those pipelines arrive
but that's conversations which which are
ongoing i can't put a figure on it now
of how much extra gas we could
potentially get through that specific
pipeline and in what timeline but it's
something we're very much working on
alongside our conversations with other
different suppliers
there is one country name name of our
country which is missing on yesterday
papers and that's iran
i'm asking this because the americans
are preparing also in case we have a
revival of a
nuke deal with iran
how to use
once the sanction are lifted
to use the iran oil
so
is you also planning longer term
uh
how to to bring that gas from iran to
the eu and eventually through which
territory
which country
i think that's that's a little bit more
speculative and i i look to peter um who
knows the situation there in the jcpoa
discussions and the context of those a
bit better than i do but i yeah i think
at this stage i have nothing to say on
that
absolutely
david
energy
energy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
possible
mercy
now i have a question on energy
go ahead we can hear you go ahead
uh yes uh thank you eric
i would like to ask if the commission is
in contract
or visits are planned with the gulf
countries on the diversification of
energy thank you
i think i can answer that positively
we've said it uh quite a few times that
indeed we were but perhaps you can
provide some more detail
yeah now so we we've had conversations
um with a number of of countries in the
region and those conversations uh
continue and will continue um that
happens at the level of president van
der lion
commissioner simpson executive vice
president tim runs higher ups and high
representative vice president borrel and
of course and throughout all our
services so yeah we are we are looking
to to diversify our sources uh that's
that's something we've been working on
for uh for several months uh already
going back as far as
last summer last autumn when we noted
the price is increasing due to due to
the supply squeeze in the global market
and that's the situation which has been
exacerbated
by the current
situation
in ukraine and that's why we continue to
pursue these talks
okay i see no further questions on
energy so we move to other topics yes
thank you it's it's a question regarding
crisis management
after yesterday um
just so sorry
thanks
so my question is that yesterday the
commission proposed measures to sort of
soften the blow of rising energy
prices according to researchers we're
going to see
a rise in
in a likely rise in food prices as well
that may be as high as
20 to 50 percent is that something the
commission is looking into at the moment
uh or can you see similar programs be
sort of called to call for for sorry
um
uh to start a hearing process on similar
uh proposals with regarding to combat
food prices
thanks sorry yeah thank you very much um
well of course the commission is
monitoring the overall economic
situation very very closely
based on
the impact that the invasion of ukraine
has
uh to go to the example that you have
mentioned which is indeed an extremely
important one it's clear as well that
there is a link to
the rise in energy prices because
obviously
energy is an important input into the
production of foodstuffs
be it because you need fuel for tractors
be it because the production of
fertilizers requires energy
etc etc so this is something which the
commission is um is tracking um very
closely um and of course
we will if need be come forward uh with
our position on this but for the moment
we are focusing uh in terms of proposals
on uh the most pressing issue uh the
most immediate issue i would say which
is um which is energy while following up
on all the different economic aspects
that uh this
crisis is having on the european union
are there other questions for us today
related to ukraine
no any other issues for us
no so thank you very much and we will
see you tomorrow for the last midday
briefing of the week since on friday uh
there will be a press conference at the
end of the informal summit in versailles
with president from the lion thank you
very much see you tomorrow
you